the new leader of the Democrats
congresswoman Acacio Cortez is now
continuing her far-left crusade against
anything everything President Trump but
this one itsy-bitsy problem reality just
keeps getting in the way
now she was recently asked about her top
three reasons to impeach the president
got a little trouble answering the
question kind of becoming common take a
look you could reach in a bag and pull
so many things out that are impeachable
of this president I support impeaching
this president two and three two and
three
I think two would be tax fraud and
number three man I mean there's just
there's just so much census there's you
know I I can't even the the tax bill
it's like what can like there's just so
much can't find one I'm what I'm working
on it
I also ramping up her radicalism on
foreign policy and taking aim at one of
our most important allies take a look at
this I think what we're really seeing is
the a sense of authoritarianism across
the world I think that Netanyahu is a
trump-like figure would you be in favor
of reducing military or economic aid to
Israel I mean I think it's on the table
I think it's not certainly on the table
and I think it's something that that can
be discussed
now while the Democratic primary is just
beginning Acacio Cortes is already
making one thing clear as the one Joe
Biden to be the nominee oh boy I guess
she decides not Nancy Pelosi take a look
this idea that we can go back to the
good old days with Obama with Obama's
vice president and I think you know
there's there's a there's an emotional
element to that but I I don't want to go
back I want to go forward it was
reaction founder of skybridge Capital
Anthony scaramouche a Fox News
contributor Rachel Campos stuffy is with
us our mooch good to see you man hey
great to be here shot alright so there's
so many things but where do you want to
start I'll start there I would say aoc
out of New York ASAP that would be my
first thing to say yeah
secondarily I think Nancy Pelosi whose
daughter said that she could cut
somebody's throat without them even
feeling it he's gonna take her out I
think she's only five of these
extremists of the party she's scared to
death of the five you think so though I
don't know about that I think is a
hundred supporting new Green a
remarkably successful survivor in
Washington and she's old school and this
sort of behavior I don't think it's
gonna last very long it's just my honest
opinion they'll find somebody to
challenge her in that district Crowley
will probably not come back but somebody
more moderate I think we'll take her
lights out I don't know she destroyed
herself with this whole Amazon thing so
she's colorful she's got some
interesting ways to attract attention to
herself but I think I think New York's
getting tired of her pretty quickly well
we'll see what did you make of Pelosi's
comment in a little fluffball interview
Rachel on 60 minutes oh there's only
five but when it comes to congresswoman
Omar and Talib and Acacio Cortes antsy
Pelosi doesn't seem to have or shown any
ability to stand up to them but Nancy
Pelosi isn't with the Democrat Party the
heart of the Democrat Party is with
representative Omar
Egon Omar and with Alexandra Cortes and
by the way the socialist Bernie Sanders
is the number-one presidential candidate
right now I mean he's got all the energy
the party the Democrat Party is a
socialist party so when Acacio Cortez
says we don't want to go backwards yeah
she means we don't want an old white man
fighting but she also means we want to
embrace socialism wholly completely and
what the economically ignorant
Alexandria cacio Cortes doesn't
understand even though she has a degree
in economics from Boston you shame on
you Boston you is that socialism is
going backward those ideas are old those
ideas have never worked and it's a
danger for the country the kind of
popularity and mainstreaming that
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez and Bernie
Sanders have right now whether Nancy
wants to admit it or not Anthony besides
Oh crazy creepy Uncle Joe Biden which
you'll have to deal with the hardest
thing he's gonna have to deal with this
oh you're going to bring back the the
same policies on giving mullahs 150
billion so they can buy and foment
terror and fight proxy wars where he's
got the Ukraine issue as well he's got
to address that's a huge issue I told
your friend Jesse that he's male he's
pale and he stale you happen to be male
and pale but you're very not stale Sean
so you have to understand I think the
guys but here's the thing
economics is your wheelhouse mm-hmm new
Green Deal okay we're gonna get rid of
oil and gas the lifeblood of our economy
Calabar chillin combustion engine yep
then everything is going to be free
everything whether you're willing or
unwilling to work then the cars yeah the
airplanes I don't know how we're gonna
get to forgot the cows but I think this
is like a fabulous thing because like I
like steak for you on a restaurant wall
I have a hunt and and fish club manone
you have everything I tell you I mean
you know I just love all this stuff
because it's like great for the
president I mean at the end of the day
people look at that and they'll say okay
maybe not gonna tell my friend in LA
that I'm voting for him but with them
when they close the booth he has to
reverse Bradley effect people say
they're not going to vote for the
president they closed the curtain you
can a vote for the president not a whole
Donald Trump pack as I'm saying so I
think he wins by 60 per day if they keep
it up it's a step function about the
amount of percentage that he'll win by
quick last response geez John keep keep
shining a light on the hypocrisy of
these socialists with very rich taste
she lives in an apartment with a
infinity pool on the penthouse Bernie
Sanders loves to fly private jets so
they talk a good game but he even said
today on the townhall that he is not
interested in paying the tax rate that
he proposes right now so they've they're
hypocrites yeah watch you know don't do
as I do do as I say oh great
and I'm a millionaire but I liberals are
only generous with other people's money
so that's the number one